all right Ryan one of the things that
we've been seeing most requested on our
site is should people buy the
battlefield hardline deluxe edition for
an extra ten dollars so that brings it
up to you know sixty nine ninety nine
versus $59.99 for that you get ten gold
battlepacks a versatility battle pack
precision and suppression battle pack
and each of those comes with a new
weapon the real question is should
people pay an extra ten dollars for an
extra three weapons all of which I'll
add are only on one class the operator
yeah they're all operator class weapons
so there's no love for mechanic enforcer
or professional let's talk about where
this extra ten dollars is going
conceptually I'm having a problem right
now with visceral 'z commitment to some
of the initial ideas such as faction
based weapons being able to purchase
these three weapons they come with
licenses so they're already all factions
it definitely has a pay2win quality to
it and if if for no other reason than
because they're the only weapons
currently in the game that are both that
for both factions and that means that
somebody who really likes planning
operator which is arguably the more
powerful of the classes can pick one of
those three weapons that they like well
enough and they can use it all the time
that means that they do kind of have an
unfair advantage when it comes to you
know getting experience with a specific
weapon because when you're going between
cops and criminals you can just maintain
that one weapon right from the get-go
and probably the best battlefield
players just somebody who sticks with
the first weapon they're good at and
doesn't try anything else exactly in
this case there's three options for one
class and I think that you know anybody
could pay the extra ten bucks is going
to find that one of those three weapons
works really well for them okay so
that's how we feel about it conceptually
probably I would be against this but
let's talk about mechanically are these
weapons balanced are people paying $10
for an advantage in the game other than
being able to switch between factions
well my opinion is that the ACW is the
best
assault rifle available to the police
faction
so the acw-r out of the box comes with
the compensator which makes a huge
difference in controllability so it kind
of makes it the rival to the aks-74u
that the criminals get so now the police
have sort of the answer to that weapon
and I had quite a lot of success with it
out of these weapons I found myself
gravitating towards the car five five
six just because it has a lower rate of
fire but it's extremely accurate has
almost no recoil and I found it to be
one of the best ranged weapons for the
operator class in my opinion and also
there you know the extra ammo you have
to get used to not hitting reload all
the time but it's kind of nice you know
if you have a catch a couple guys at
range you can drop two guys without
reloading yeah I agree with that
entirely because I'd say that when I
look at the attachment options in that
that section of the weapons menu where
you've got the flashlight attack light
the laser sight and extended mags like
I've been going with extended mags every
time like I don't really find much use
for the flashlight and I don't think
that the laser sights is necessary is it
maybe it used to be when we dealt with
weapons ahead a lot wider spread back in
battlefield 4 and having those extra
rounds is really helpful so that's
another thing I guess you know the car
five five six out of the butt out of the
box is going to have more ammo and it
comes with a decent sight - I think so
you've got pretty competitive weapon
there - and the last one the l85a2 I
just couldn't wrap my head around this
weapon it seemed like it was their
battle rifle of the operator class it
felt like you'd have too much recoil too
much spread and I felt like in almost
any other situation I would have won
engagements with another weapon if it
hadn't been that gun in my hands I think
that sort of like how I think the acw-r
is is comparable to the aks and
something for the police to use I feel
like the l85 is somewhat comparable to
the m16 8-3 and so if you're on the
criminal side and you
missing your m16 then it's a good sort
of in-between so it sounds like what
you're saying touches back so what we
said earlier which is kind of this drift
away already from the commitment to
faction based weaponry and granted you
can buy licenses to do that but they
take a huge number of kills and a lot of
cash to get that right yeah you need a
thousand two hundred and fifty kills of
the weapon to unlock the license and
then to buy it for the other faction you
have to drop fifty thousand which you
know by the time you've gotten over a
thousand kills with a gun you probably
got plenty of cash in the bank to afford
it but that's a lot of work so the
deluxe edition is basically could
potentially be saving you weeks of
effort right and those ten gold
battlepacks are going to give you a lot
of boosts too so it's also saving your
time on XP and levelling up so it is
kind of a ten dollar pay to win so Ryan
you think the deluxe edition is pay to
win I disagree a little bit I think that
a lot of these weapons don't do anything
particularly well or well enough than
other weapons you can already have in
the game to really justify buying them
so I don't know in conclusion I would
say if you have an extra $10 to spare
and you haven't already dropped another
$60 in premium I guess you might as well
have three more guns in this game if you
don't if you're not like morally opposed
to paying for weapons in battlefield but
I personally have a problem with it
I don't like pulling weapons out of
games even you know particularly aim
where there aren't that many per class
to start off with I would say a very
very hesitant buy if you want more
weapons and you like having more options
it gives you that for the operator class
all right thanks for watching and stay
tuned to game spot com for more coverage
of battlefield hardline